and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review
Citizen Kane
oh my god this is the worst movie I've
ever seen in my life
he says this is the greatest movie of
all time it's bullcrap this movie bills
monkeys
I mean say what you want about early
1940s cinematography and how this film
was a breakthrough in cinematic
development but for me he's no angle
camera shot seen this shining of a
certain kind of pretentiousness and his
hobbies this person's life is supposed
to be parallel to that of William
Randolph Hearst this hobby it's
one-sided portrayal of the man's life is
unfounded yes her stead Falls but what
man didn't so would say that certain
filmmaker named Orson Welles was also a
little bit of an egomaniac at least
William Randolph Hearst to eat himself
into explosion ISM is that even word it
should be fool I get it the low angle
shots are supposed to symbolize that
even though since he gave us the
election he is still ironically a large
man very southern and how dare you
attack his wife Marion Devi she was
often Percy doesn't know nothing actress
by the next round a she had a very
intelligent night she had a wonderful
sense of humor and she even know how to
take certain criticism from certain
filmmakers with grace and ease which is
more than I can say for you mr. Welles
and how about that hammer didn't see
where he's looking at - Mears obviously
showing your reflection of her
reflection yes I know that we look in
the mirror all you can see is yourself
and so your voice - looking to the
depths of your own soul I know Karen
people say that Citizen Kane is - the
cinematic world what Shakespeare was -
the theatrical world its County that's
right I said County and then trying to
recant at the end by trying to show it's
because he had no childhood through that
obvious not very simple simple I'm sorry
mr. Welles
it doesn't work after what you've taken
away from that man perhaps you should
take your own cinematic perceptive and
point it at your own soul and see how
you're dead that's probably the only
thing you can point to that Citizen Kane
sucks
the sooner we realize this the sooner we
can move on to making greater cinematic
masterpieces let's be racer go Speed
Racer go this is just a wee phone scene
change
come on J let's copy the Seventh Seal
I hear that will be supposed to mean and
worse